Musik Wie macht ihr das immer, wie fangt ihr immer an? Also ihr redet bestimmt erstmal zehn Minuten, weil ihr euch dann zusammensetzt. Und dann sagt ihr dann, jetzt ist der Moment, wo wir aufnehmen und dann begrüsste nochmal und jetzt entsteht diese weirde Situation, wobei man weiß nicht genau, wer redet jetzt und wer begrüsst jetzt schon und nehmen wir schon auf oder wie ist das bei euch? Ja, wir zanken auch ein bisschen darum, wer die Begrüßung spricht. Nachdem ich einmal in einer Folge von allen beleidigt wurde, als ich die Begrüßung gesagt habe, und die gesagt haben, ich zog mal auf mit so einer Moderatorenbegrüßung, seitdem weigere ich mich zu begrüßen. Du wirst schon gemobbt auch, weil du so viel Erfahrung hast. Ich bin auch bemobbt, weil ich sprechen kann, ja. Sehr gut. Ich auch. Das ist ja witzig, ich auch. Ich habe neulich mal nochmal gesagt. Boah, was für ein natürliches authentisches Gespräch gerade am Laufen ist. Ich würde es gerade ganz gerne ungern gerade beenden. Ich bin auch nie so dankbar, dass ich irgendwann ein Gespräch angeklingt habe. Mag das total gern, wenn man irgendwie der Podcast losgeht und es ist einfach so ein ganz authentisches, normales Gespräch. Man tut so, als wenn man noch gar nicht angefangen hätte. Ich habe gerade mein Booster Energy Drink TM Trademark getrunken und schon ging es einfach los. Ja, herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu das Podcast-Support. Hallo Florian. Und heute mit Mäpp, Mäpp, Mäpp, Mäpp, Mäpp. Ich dachte, dass du währenddessen redest vielleicht, dass ich nicht so ganz beschissen dastehe. Nee, cool, cool, cool. Ich soll das jetzt singen? Nein, du sollst einfach reden, während ich das im Hintergrund sage. Ach so, ah ja. Ich habe mir eine Sache aufgetrieben auf meinem fucking Text. Da klappt er super. Okay, los. Hier ist Nils Bokeberg von Gäste ist der Geisterbahn. Okay, herzlich willkommen. Und hier ist Herm. Dankeschön. Hier ist Herm. Herm. Nee, der rutscht er ja nicht so wie du. Aber müsste er eigentlich machen. Du bist ja professioneller R-Sprecher. Ich bin professioneller R-Sprecher. Willst du gleich jetzt mit deinem Zeugnis anfangen? Ich habe jeden Buchstabend eine Note, R war eine Eins. Ich habe im Sprechen eine Eins bekommen. Also Leute, alles, was ihr heute sagt, ist mit Sicherheit falsch und ich kann es mit Sicherheit korrigieren, also kein Problem. Wir kriegen das hin. Jetzt in dem Bereich Moderation gab es hundert mögliche Punkte zu holen. Nils, was denkst du, wie viele von diesen hundert möglichen Punkten hat der Stefan sich geholt? Wie oft hat er in den Talersack gegriffen und hat sich da Punkte rausgeholt? Also was ich vom Podcast UFO kenne, muss das auf jeden Fall im höheren zweistelligen Bereich bewegen. Oh, das ist aber sehr nett. Oh! Das ist aber jetzt schon mal sehr nett. Also ich hätte mit allem im Einstelligenbereich schon zufrieden gewesen. Aber okay, es waren 97 Punkte tatsächlich. 97? Ich finde es unfassbar übertrieben von 100. Aber naja, die Noten werden dann hinterhergeschmissen. Ich meine, da kann man nicht ganz gut leben. Aber ich denke, dass es nicht so ganz so gut ist, dass wir es am Anfang verraten haben. Weil jetzt wird natürlich der Gemeindehörer erwartet sehr viel von mir moderativ. Ich habe mir deswegen auch ein paar Fragen aufgeschrieben, aber die habe ich jetzt noch nicht raus. Wer ist denn Nils eigentlich überhaupt? Nils und ich, wir kennen uns ja schon ewig eigentlich. Ja, du und ich, das ist so. Also wir kennen uns ja schon ewig eigentlich. Du und ich, wir durften uns nie verlieren. Oder so, ne? Habe ich es nicht verstanden? Da merkt man, wir sind, wir kennen uns zwar schon aus dem Kindergarten, aber er ist doppelt so alt. Ihr wart nie auf einer Welt. Zwei, da gibt es dieses Lied von Ullinberg, wonach auch ein Musical in Berlin benannt ist, hinter dem Horizont? Hinter dem Horizont. Und da singt er doch zwei wie wir, die durften sich nie verlieren. Das stimmt, ja. Ich war da drin tatsächlich. Da war ich gerade Bezug genommen. Ich war da drin tatsächlich in die Musical. Aber dafür werden die auf jeden Fall wieder zehn Punkte abgezogen. Sorry. Ja, ist okay. Es war wirklich nicht so schlecht. Ich finde immer Musicals relativ lustig, die nicht als Musicals gedacht sind, sondern wo einfach ganz viele Songs, die nicht irgendwie im Zusammenhang stehen, irgendwie zusammengewurschtelt werden. Und dann so eine ganz komische Geschichte, so eine komische, random Geschichte werden die Verbunden, die Songs. Aber so eins ist das halt, aber nicht ganz gut sogar tatsächlich. Die Songs waren ja auch ... Die Songs waren ja auch ... Entschuldigung, ja. Hast du da was gelernt über die Geschichte der Teilung Berlins? Ja, es war eine Mauer da, die war irgendwann weg. Es war im Prinzip die Geschichte in Zusammen... Was ich so geil am Nies finde, ist einfach, dass er irgendwie auch keine Angst hat, irgendwie neue Dinge auszuprobieren und einfach sich völlig in neue Themenbereiche stürzt und einfach sagt, gut, ich bin jetzt vielleicht schon ein bisschen älter, aber ich will es einfach nochmal wissen. Ich probiere es einfach nochmal, ich gehe nochmal rein. Du hast jetzt auch einen Podcast gegründet tatsächlich. Ich habe auch einen Podcast, ja. Und das finde ich einfach so toll, dass er sagt, nicht nur... Finden wir das gut eigentlich? Ich habe nicht nur einen Blog, ich habe nicht nur eine erfolgreiche Kochshow, Kochshow... Ja, ja, Kochshow. Spiel, Spielshow. Mach einen Daumen, gib mir einen Daumen. Kochshow ist so... Spielshow, eine Casino-Show, eine Live-Show, Variety. Nimm das Wahrscheinlichste, das Wahrscheinlichste ist eine Casino-Show. Casino... Da fährt man eigentlich immer ganz... Diese Fallschirmshow. Auf der Fallschirmshow. Fallschirm. Fallschirm-Casino-Show. Casino-Show. Wenn man auf der Party jemanden trifft, einfach, ich rate mal. Casino-Varieté. Und da stehen die Frauen richtig gut drauf, wenn man ihren Beruf errät. Das ist eine Casino-Varieté. Roulette mit Roulette in Strapsen. Ja, genau. Hast du mal Roulette gespielt tatsächlich? Nee. Ich habe aber immer gedacht, wenn ich mal ins Casino gehe, dann interessiert mich Roulette auch nicht, weil da fühlen sich die Chancen am schlechtesten an. Ich wollte immer Blackjack spielen, weil ich gedacht habe, naja gut, da kann man die Karten. Na gut, zähle ich die Karten halt. Es gibt ja jetzt, ich habe mal 72 Karten. Roulette ist ja dieses Ding, wo ich gehört habe, da gab ich mal so einen Trick, dass man, wenn man einmal auf Rot setzt und es kommt nicht Rot, muss man das Doppelte auf Schwarz setzen. Und wenn das immer noch nicht kommt, muss man das Doppelte davon wieder auf Rot setzen und immer so weiter. Und wenn man gewinnt, muss man halt wieder von vorne anfangen. Das wäre so ein ganz einfacher Logarithmus. Das ist ein Verdoppelungstrick, so dass auch wenn du immer verlierst, wenn du irgendwann mal gewinnst, holst du alles wieder rein, was du geholt hast. Und noch mehr. Und schon sind sie immer 50-50. Und ich habe das dann versucht, hatte aber nur 10 Euro
auf Klassenfarben mit. Wir waren gerade 18,
konnte man ins Casino gehen in Berlin, dann
habe ich das gemacht mit 10 Euro, aber das Geld hat relativ
schnell weg, weil man irgendwann 10 Euro halt setzen muss auf eine
Farbe und wenn die nicht reinkommt, ist halt verloren.
Aber wenn du sehr viel Geld hast, kann man glaube ich sehr viel
reichen. Du kannst es gar nicht schlagen.
Es gibt wahnsinnig viele so Spamseiten,
oh, werde schnell reich im Internet, mit diesem
Casino-Trick. Und diese Tricks werden natürlich von Online-Casinos gestreut, weil sie funktionieren einfach nicht. Sie wirken sehr gut, weil der Mensch einfach stochastisch sehr unintuitiv ist. Er denkt, ja, wenn Rot ja ja schon mal kam, dann ist beim nächsten Mal die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Rot kommt, ja ein bisschen geringer. Und dann denkt man sich, okay, wenn ich immer wieder auf Rot setze, irgendwann muss Rot ja kommen, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit wird ja immer geringer, was nicht stimmt.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist immer 50%.
So, aber da ist der Mensch intuitiv einfach sehr schlecht und das kann man sehr gut ausnutzen.
Deswegen, Leute da draußen, wirklich, lasst euch nicht auf diese Endlosspirale rein.
Klar, Nils ist ein Casino-Freak und ich will hier überhaupt nicht, ich will hier gar nicht reingrätschen.
Ich will auch deine Show nicht kaputt machen.
Du, ohne Witz, deine Tiger-Lama-Show ist ist immer noch super geil und dafür gehe ich gerne ins Casino. Aber
Leute, von den Roulettischen. Auf einem
Kreuzfahrtschiff habe ich mal ein Räschchen geschrieben.
Also nicht Kreuzfahrtschiff,
auf einer Fähre. Unser Gast wollte gerade was sagen.
Ich wollte auch was sagen.
Und nur weil er Gasse ist jetzt plötzlich.
Was hast du, du hast auf
einem Kreuzfahrtschiff?
Auf einer Fähre, wenn man so von Dänemark nach
England fährt und dann ist man so für 20 Minuten irgendwie so im Weltraum,
so da gelten die Gesetze nicht, weil da sind die Grenzen, so für 20 Meter gibt es keine Gesetze, da ist so gesetzesfreier Raum.
Zollfreie Zogen, wie die normale Menschen sagen.
Und dann irgendwie plötzlich kommt der Alkohol raus, irgendwie die Kinder werden vergewaltigt und es wird Glücksspiel betrieben.
Und dann fährt so ein Casinotisch aus dem Boden.
Ja, genau, und dann kann man irgendwie Billard spielen, aber es schwankstätig.
Und so eine Disco-Kugel kommt aus der Decke und alle so, yeah, die Tiere fangen an zu sprechen, weird, was ist hier los? So wie die Sauerstoffmasken, einfach bei jedem so ein Ding. So ein Narnia. Ja, genau. Das Problem ist, dass das Schiff die ganze Zeit schwankt. Das heißt, du hast diese Roulette-Kugel, die sich im schlechtesten Fall unendlich lange einfach dreht. Es schwenkt immer, weil es kommt immer im Energieansystem. Es greift ja wieder eine ganz andere Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung und das wird nur erklärt bei mir auf dem Casino. Ja, da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Ja, da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Ja, da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Da muss man immer auf dem Casino gar nicht. Ich habe mir ein paar Fragen aufgeschrieben. Ich habe mir zwei Fragen aufgeschrieben. Also eine ist, eine davon ist, bist du Banksy? Banksy? Achso, ja. Weil wir die jedem vorstellen wollten, weil irgendwann... Wenn ich sage, nee, dann ist es ja ganz auffällig. Ja, dann würde ich in den näheren Kreis stehen, aber wir wissen selber nicht, wo diese Frage hinschaut. Das ist echt so scheiße, das ist so eine scheissart von Moderation. Entschuldigung, ich habe 97 Punkte in der Moderation. Es ist immer so Dinge zu machen, wo der Gast dann deliveren muss. Aber dafür kommt ein Gast da, oder nicht? Aber ich finde, meine Grundregel ist, ich finde, man muss den Gast in Situationen bringen, in denen er performen kann, aber nicht in denen er performen muss. Ja, ich verstehe. Und es gibt oft so Radiosendungen, wo es dann heisst, ey, du bist doch Comedian, so irgendwas ist denn deine Meinung zu Griechenland, so und dann musst du, da hast du einfach keine Ahnung. Das stimmt. Und das ist scheiße so. Und gute Talkshow-Hose irgendwie, Jimmy Fallon, die schaffen es, Leute in eine Situation zu bringen, wo sie scheinen können, aber nicht unbedingt müssen und nicht dumm dastehen, wenn sie es nicht tun. Also wenn wie Nils jetzt, wenn die Gangs ein bisschen spärlicher kommen am Anfang der Folge, dass er dann nicht komplett nicht komplett scheiße aussieht. Aber der Banksy, aber das war doch schön, der Banksy. Ich habe 97 Punkte, also nicht 100, aber ich glaube trotzdem, man sollte den Gast vorher nicht beleidigen. Man sollte den Gast, der sind jetzt die ersten 10 Minuten, der ist in 10 Minuten, die ja fehlen. Aber du hast ja schon 10 abgezogen bekommen. Ach ja, sorry. Weißt du, was ich glaube, Stefan? Ich glaube, wenn ich diese Prüfung machen würde, ich würde drei Punkte bekommen. Zusammen haben wir die 100 Prozent, die denn gemacht. Und zusammen sind wir perfekt. Das war schauspielisch und grandios, aber wir haben leider keine Kamera. Ja, Nils hat reingeredet. Aber sehr gut. Wer hat denn die Prüfung gemacht? Stefan Raab. Ich weiß nicht genau, was das war. Da war immer so eine Frau, die hat gemeint, sie gemeint, sie putzt da immer, aber ich, also wir haben sie mal
das so schlecht rübergebracht, das kann nicht sein,
sie hat das so rübergebracht, die muss eine
Schauspielerin sein oder so, da haben wir halt immer gedacht,
ja okay, warum sich das
Putzoutfit anzieht.
Dieses Putzoutfit, dachten wir, das ist übertrieben.
Naja, also too much.
Naja, aber halt sieben Punkte, ich sag's nur noch.
Ich hab heute YouTuber gesehen, ich war halt,
ich hab mir heute KFC geholt. Du bist ja auch YouTuber. Ja, auch YouTuber. Musste ich ich bis gestern gar nicht. Bist du meine Vorbereitungssage. Die goldene Überleitung. Indem man den Co-Moderator komplett kaputt macht. Lass mich doch die Anebote einmal kurz erzählen. Ich hab mich heute mit so einem richtig schönen Höhchenkeule, die noch halb gelebt hat, irgendwie aus so einer Massentierhaltung, die noch halb gezappelt hat, so Schweiss und Fett triefend, da habe ich mich einfach vor den Dom gesetzt, weil ich mir dachte, fuck it, warum nicht, und ich habe YouTuber gesehen, und zwar zwei von Apecrime, Andre und Gengis. Okay. Du bist da da drin im YouTuber? Ja, jetzt muss ich was sagen. Ah, Andre und Gengis, mhm. Von Apecrime ist es ein Andres, ein YouTube-Teller. Was ist jetzt die angemessene Reaktion? Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt machen soll. Es ist ja immer so... Weinen vielleicht. Oh Mann, ich werde den ganzen Pop-Culturen-Hintergrund erinnern. Wuh, ey, wuh, warst du das andere, ein Gengis-Ges? Es ist ja so ein bisschen das Klischee, dass Köln so die YouTuber-Hochburg ist und dass man irgendwie rumkommt und sofort in einem Vlog irgendwie ist, wenn man aussteigt aus dem Zug. Und deswegen fand ich es humoristisch interessant, dass es tatsächlich so war, dass ich YouTuber gesehen habe. Und zwar sind die vorm Dom auf ihren Longboards gefahren. Ach so, okay. Jetzt habe ich den Witz zum Schreiben. Erst den Witz, dann der
Kontext. Die ganzen Gagdetails haus aber jetzt erst auch im Nachhinein raus. Das mit dem Longboard
ist ja auch so ein Klischee. Das ist ja auch vorlustig. Ja, da will ich doch am Ende hinkommen, du.
Also, ich haus jetzt einfach ganz nüchtern runter. Das ist immer eine schwere Geburt.
Es ist jetzt scheißegal, ich haus jetzt einfach ganz nüchtern runter. Das ist immer eine schwere Geburt. Es ist jetzt scheißegal, ich haue es jetzt einfach ganz nüchtern runter. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe die beiden YouTuber gesehen, wie sie mit Longboards vor dem Dom gefahren sind und hinter ihnen ungelogen wirklich so eine Schar Fans, die ihnen einfach hinterher gelaufen ist. Und nicht so als Event irgendwie, wir laufen jetzt durch Berlin irgendwie, so Marathon-mäßig, sondern wirklich so Ich-will-dich-berühren-mäßig, wie so eine Zombie-Schar, hinter denen hergelaufen ist, die sie immer so weit verfolgt haben, bis sie sie nicht mehr sehen konnten und dann abgebogen sind und wieder sich verlaufen haben. Und da haben plötzlich auch die Longboards Sinn ergeben für mich, dass die YouTuber diese Longboards haben, einfach um den Fans davon zu fahren, tatsächlich, um fliehen zu können. Aber es ist nur so cool, bis die Fans diesen Trend aufgreifen und einfach immer besser fahren. Die YouTuber müssen reiten auf so Sadways, die in den Trend immer mit so Drohnen, jagen sich plötzlich. Habt ihr nichts aus dem kalten Weltkrieg gelernt? Fuck it, ey, gute Pointe, aber versprochen. Schade. Naja. Sprecht da nicht, ich weiß, das ist nur noch ein Fähl. Auf jeden Fall war das tatsächlich sehr beengt. Aber ganz kurz noch mal zum Thema Massentierhaltung, weil wir müssen... Aber ganz kurz noch zum Thema Fans. Vielleicht ist es kurz noch bei Fans bleiben. Es war so interessant, dass Fans früher, als ich so bei Beaver war, ich war damals bei Beaver und dann gab es ja auch so Fans, die das so ganz toll fand. Gut, dass du ansprichst, ja. Und da war das immer so, wenn ich durch die Stadt gelaufen bin, dass die mich nie angesprochen haben, aber wenn ich so fünf Meter an denen vorbeigelaufen war, dann haben die sich immer umgeregt mit Nönt! Ja, und das war's auch. Das war die vollständige Interaktion. Man hat immer gewartet, dass ich mich umdrehe und dann so auf die zugehe oder so und sage, hey, da seid ihr ja!
Aber du bist da ein bisschen erfahrener, kannst du mir vielleicht mal als, sag ich mal, Nils Bokelberg in Spee, Zukunft Nils Bokelberg, das wünsche ich dir nicht.
Ich mal ein paar Tipps geben, wie man da mitgeht.
Wenn eine Comedy-Persona wird von Folge zu Folge arrogant da reinreist und schliesst mit Sympathien einfach voll ab, ist okay.
Ja, ja, ein Sympathiv nach dem nächsten Jahr. Und bei mir ist es oft so, ich laufe an jemandem vorbei und der sagt dann, hey, du bist doch der Beef-Träger. Und dann kommt dieser Moment, wo man sich entscheiden kann, bleibe ich stehen oder laufe ich weiter. Einerseits, wenn ich stehen bleibe, bin ich in einem Gespräch drin und vielleicht will er dieses Gespräch gar nicht und dann stehe ich so da, als würde ich Anerkennung erfischen wollen, sondern stehe ich da und so, ja und was, ohne du gehst weiter auf die Gefallen, Arroganz zu wirken. Was machst du? Grüssend weitergeben. Naja, also wenn er dir eine Frage entsteht oder auf dich zukommt und die die Hand geben will und so, dann ist klar. Aber wenn er nur sagt, hey, du bist doch der Beefträger und soll es anstehen bleiben oder nicht? Jetzt eine Antwort ja und nein. Ich bin da, glaube ich, selten stehen geblieben, wenn es einfach nur so wäre, ey, du bist doch Nils oder so, aber ich habe dann immer gesagt, irgendwie sowas gesagt wie, yeah, hey, so was kann man nicht. Nachdem du fünf Minuten dann überlegt hast, was du sagen willst, yeah, eine Reaktion zeigen, aber nicht irgendwie, ich meine, der will ja sowieso kein Gespräch mit dir, der will ja nur dir sagen, dass er dich erkannt hat. Aber man, die Top-Tender-Jugendwörter 2015 irgendwie rauszuhören, einfach nachher rufen, yeah, geil, einfach cool. Das sind Top-Jugendwörter aus 2015 irgendwie rauszuhören und einfach nachher rufen. Yeah, geil, Alpha-Cool.
Das sind Top-Jugendwörter.
Yeah und geil.
Alpha-Kevin ist ein Wort, was aber jetzt, glaube ich, gestrichen wurde.
Aber stimmt, dürfen die Jugendlichen jetzt nicht mehr sagen.
Genau, das ist ja das Ding.
Merkel, Merkel.
Merkel.
Das hast du aber gut gemerkt.
Um den heißen Preis herumreden.
Könntest du sagen.
Das hast du gut gemerkt, dass ich der Bief-Träger bin. Tja. Dann wärst du bei der Jugend und dann wärst du bei denen. Aber er hat sich auch noch ein, was es, was die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, diese Leute davon erwarten, einen Star zu treffen, kann nur enttäuscht werden. Weil du hast diese Lichtgestalten, die Spokelberg vor Augen. Ich bin so gut, dass du mich thematisch gerade voll aus dem Thema rausnimmst. Und dann kannst du ja nur enttäuscht werden. Weil du hast diese Lichtgestalten, die es Bokelberg vor Augen. Ich bin so gut, dass du mich thematisch gerade voll aus dem Thema rausnimmst.
Und dann kannst du ja nur enttäuscht werden.
Das ist für mich der magische Moment, wo ich in den Augen
des Fans merke, da bricht eine Welt zusammen.
Diese leeren Augen,
diese Desillusionierung,
wo einfach das Leben
aus den Augen gesaugt wird. Wie ist es bei dir?
Ich habe da viele zurückgelassen und ich musste
weitergehen. Ich musste weitergehen.
Man muss einen eigenen Weg gehen.
Ich konnte sie nicht alle retten. Ich musste meinen eigenen Weg gehen.
Noch heute ist die
hohe Straße geflastert von Menschen, denen ich
damals irgendwie die kalte Schulter gezeigt habe.
Sind viele Tränen geflossen? Kannst du vielleicht ein bisschen näher ins Mikrofon
gehen, bitte? Noch heute ist die hohe Straße
voll von vielen Menschen, denen ich
damals die kalte Schulter gezeigt habe.
Alles, was du eben gesagt hast im Laufe des Gesprächs noch mal näher am Mikro sagen.
Sorry, wir sind nicht über das Professor mehr.
Und jetzt, ich ziehe das mal einfach näher ran, pass auf, ich ziehe das mal näher ran.
Der Podcast-Ufo mit Jingle.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Service.
Heute in das Podcast-Ufo-Service bieten wir euch an, Nils Bokeberg bespricht eure Mailbox. Dingelilililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililililil Deine Mutter hat auch schon bei mir angerufen und die suchen dich auch und keiner weiss, du hast doch gesagt, du willst nur nach Berlin und auf die ins Berghain, aber jetzt weiss keiner mehr, wo du bist und du bist gefeuert und dein Chef hat angerufen, dass du nie wieder zurückkommen brauchst, weil dich alle hassen in der Firma und ich auch, du Schwein tut. Ich finde es gut, dass Nils einfach seinen Mailbox bespricht, als wäre das Handy auf der anderen Flussseite. Ich bin gar nicht erreichbar! Es war so eine Emotion, aus der Emotion heraus. Ich habe das Mikro jetzt so nah, dass du aussiehst wie ein Bankräuber, weil ich dich die ganze Zeit nicht einen Strumpf angucken muss. Ja, er hat so einen Schnurrbart. Einen kreisrunden Schnurrbart.
Aber so sieht es so ein bisschen aus wie Ewan McGregor. Ist das schon, ist das so ein Ding, oder Ewan McGregor? Ewan. Mir wurde ja ganz oft nahe gesagt, ich sehe aus wie Kiefer Sutherland. Wirklich? Ich hatte ja auch nichts für, ich will auch gar nicht so aussehen wie der, aber... Wenn du 24 Stunden lang nicht aufs Klo gehen musst, oder? Ja, tick, tick, tick, tick, rausgeschnitten. Rumzeler! Was war das für ein harter Schnitt? Wir müssen ja über, wir haben tatsächlich ein Pflichtthema, wir haben pro Folge ein Pflichtthema, Massentierhaltung tatsächlich, müssen wir darüber reden. Das ist so lustig, was da passiert ist. Ein Fan hat sich gewünscht, dass wir über das Thema Massentierhaltung sprechen. Nein, ein Fan hat behauptet, ein Fan hat behauptet, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch habt, Fans. Fans, ja, wir haben ja auch. Er hat jetzt diese Fragen reingeschaut gerade. War das deine zweite Frage? Nee, kommt noch. Aber es hat ein Fan gesagt, wir würden sehr oft über Massentierhaltung sprechen. Es wäre ihm schon sehr oft in so einem Podcast vorgekommen. Das wäre so ein durchgehendes Motiv bei uns, so ein roter Faden in so einem Podcast wäre Massentierhaltung. Und deswegen sollten wir bitte seine Masterarbeitsumfrage im Internet doch bitte ausfüllen zum Thema Massentierhaltung. So wollen wir uns fragen, was für eine crazy Hinleitung. Wenn wir uns fragen, könnt ihr bitte an meiner Umfrage teilnehmen, dann würdest du sagen, ja, ihr redet doch andauernd über Massentierhaltung. Ihr redet ja hier schon ständig über Massentierhaltung, einfach, aber wie willst du anders an Leute rangehen?
Massentierhaltung ist, glaube ich, eines dieser Probleme, ich glaube, das war wie damals der Holocaust, das war eine Idee, die sich sehr schlecht vermarkten lässt, so, hey, habt ihr nicht
Worte, da muss man schon ein bisschen daran arbeiten. Das ist ja offensichtlich schlecht, kommt so Ken Jebsen gegen den
Ken Jebsen ist mein Onkel. Ist aber schon zu Hause eigentlich. Ken Jebsen ist was? Dein Onkel. Dein Onkel? Dein Homie?
Auch. Nein? Okay, Jugendwort Nummer fünf raus, glaube ich noch. Es kommen noch mehr, wir sind gespannt, wir bleiben am Ball. Das Jugendwort-Bingo mit der Podcast-Bingo. Sehr gut. Ne, Massen-Tierhaltung, ist das was für dich oder sagst du boah? Ich habe mal drüber nachgedacht, ich glaube, die Marge ist sehr hoch. Die Marge ist sehr hoch. Du betrachtest es aus einem rein ökonomischen. Es ist Marketingtechnisch sehr effektiv. Ja, in der Verkaufstechnik vor allem. Aber ganz kurz. Ich glaube, Marketingtechnisch gar nicht so. Aber wieso hat er euch dann nicht vorgeschlagen, euch das Peter-Ufo zu nennen, wenn Massentierhaltung so ein häufiges Thema bei euch ist? Ah, hat er nicht vorgeschlagen. Guter Gag. Hat er, hast du sehr guter Gag. Den lasst ihr jetzt verhungern absichtlich? Entschuldigung., das war bei Florentin sehr gerne. Ich schlage es ihm vor, ja. Ne, ich meine, der Mensch, hast du manchmal nicht auch so einen Selbstzerstörungstrieb, dass du Dinge tust, die ganz bewusst ganz schlecht für dich sind, wie schlechtes Essen essen, dass du nicht nur deswegen isst, weil es gut schmeckt, sondern auch, weil du dir selber wehtun willst, weil du weisst, das ist ganz schlecht und dadurch schmeckt es noch besser. Und ich weiss nicht, also du kenne bestimmt diese Videos von Massentierhaltung, wo man dann diese ganzen Vögel sieht, die da irgendwie massakriert werden und dann irgendwie Körperteile. Wo man weinende Kühe sieht, wo ich auch gar nicht weiss, können Kühe eigentlich weinen? Oder machen die Filme das so irgendwie aus Scheiss oder machen die, haben die ja so eine Pinzette oder so eine Pipette und geben denen dann Tränen da rein oder so. Kamele können doch auch weinen. Ja, aber nicht, weil sie traurig sind. Ja, dem Schwein wird es schon das Bein abgeschnitten, aber es weint halt. Trauern Tiere dann so wie wir und weinen dann auch. Es gab doch diesen Film die Geschichte vom weinenden Kamel. Ja, die kenne ich. So eine mongolische Kamel-Doku. Da rennt sie bei mir auf eine Tür. Und da hat das Kamel geweint,
aus Traurigkeit.
Aber auf YouTube gab es ja auch diesen Film
von diesem Löwen, der sich so freut, dass er seinen alten
Pfleger wieder sieht. Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Also wenn sich Tiere freuen können, dann können die doch auch weinen.
Ja? Die dann auch auffrisst.
Ne, frisst die nicht auf.
Aber auf jeden Fall, aber ist es,
ihr kennt ja diese furchtbaren Videos, wo man dann sieht,
wie schlecht es den Tieren geht,
aber habt ihr es nicht auch manchmal, dass ihr da noch mehr Bock drauf habt, dann so KFC zu essen und so, weil es so ganz böse ist, so ganz verwerflich ist? Also auf mich haben diese Videos mal den Effekt, dass ich mir denke, wenn ich mal Bock habe, was echt Beschissens zu tun, dann gehe ich lieber zu KFC. Und wobei ich da weiß, was da alles schlecht ist. Anstatt was zu tun? Anstatt was Gutes zu tun. Ach so, anstatt was anderes Beschissenes. Hast du nicht mal diese schwachen Momente, wo du denkst, ich bin den ganzen Tag so ein toller Mensch, jetzt muss ich auch mal scheiße sein? Nee, ich gehe da echt nur hin, weil es mir schmeckt, tatsächlich. Aber bei Filmen habe ich das ganz oft. Aber es schmeckt dir auch gut, weil du weißt, dass es nicht gut ist. Ich werde komplett rausgenommen. Entschuldigung? Nö, ist mir ehrlich gesagt voll egal. Nö, jetzt glaube ich dir nicht. Doch, weil bei mir ist es auch so, ich habe gar keinen Bezug zu Tieren. Gar keinen, gar, gar, gar keinen. Ja, also möchtest du die Dominanz beweisen? Du bist das Gegenteil von Oli P. Nö, ich will dir gar nicht beweisen, die Dominanz des... Sehr gut, unsere Gäste sind immer... Genau das Gegenteil.
Das ist exakt das Gegenteil von Oli P.
Oli Werl. Von dem ich aber lach, dass er keinen Bezug zu Tieren hat.
Und er hat den grössten Bezug zu Tieren.
Und dann kommst du plötzlich... Und du hast jetzt Bezug zu Popmusik?
Ich habe jetzt Bezug zu Popmusik?
Wegen Oli P.? Bei Oli P.
Hilf mir ein bisschen.
Es sind diese Einbahnstrassen von Sätzen, die ich einfach nie irgendwo hinführe mir Tiere, sind Tiere jetzt... Ich gebe Tiere, die gucke ich mir gerne an oder so, oder finde ich lustig, aber... Welches Tier guckst du dir gerne an? Kängurus. Kängurus sind so seltsame... Niesburgberg, meine Damen und Herren, vielen Dank. Das sind so komische... Was ist das? Ist die ganze Woche noch da, Autogramme gibt es alle volle Stunde. Kann ich Autogramm haben? Was ist denn ein Känguru? Nachher machen wir vielleicht. Oder Esel, Esel finde ich auch gut. Bei Känguru versteht man ja noch, warum sie da sind. Warum denn? Weil Gott dachte damals, bei der Schöpfung, bei den Prozesses der Schöpfung, dachte er sich, er hat den Fuss als Konzept noch nicht so weit ausgenutzt. Er hat nicht genug ausgeschöpft. In diesem Konzept Fuss steht viel mehr drin als nur Gehen, sondern zum Beispiel auch Springen, glaube ich. Aber ich finde halt so, man kann so alle Tiere immer irgendwie so nachvollziehen. So Zebra, Pferd, Esel, das ist alles so ein... Okay, Zebra! Erklär mir die Auster. Erklär mir... Ja, ist halt eine Muschel. Da gibt es eine Auster, verschiedene Muscheln. Ein lebendes Schlereiben in einem Stein. Ja, weil da wird das Essen so reingetrieben und so, und das kann man dann auch wieder essen. Ganz kurz. Ich spreche jetzt von Gattungen. Moritz, du hast da gerade einen Satz gesagt. Da wird das Essen so reingetrieben, dass anscheinend in irgendeiner Dimension eine Antwort war auf, was soll denn aus dann? Du kannst nicht Dinge so betonen, als wären es Antworten und einfach hoffen, dass es einfach so durchgeht. Aber man muss ganz anderes sagen. Da wird das Essen so reingetrieben, halt was das für eine Antwort war. Okay, nächstes Thema. Aber das ist doch das Prinzip Muschel. Ich liege so und das Essen ist so. Eigentlich das Prinzip Muschel ist eigentlich Schlaraffenland. Das heißt eine Autobiografie. Das Prinzip Muschel ist eigentlich das Prinzip Schlaraffenland. Ich liege so und das Essen ist so... Eigentlich das Prinzip Muschel ist eigentlich Schlaraffenland. Das Prinzip Muschel ist eigentlich das Prinzip Schlaraffenland. Ich liege und ich habe mein Haus immer dabei, weil das an mir dranklebt und ich kriege Essen so in den Nahrung, die schwimmt so in mich rein. Eigentlich ist das wie so, als wenn mir ein Brathähnchen in den Mund fliegen würde. Ja, da musst du halt nehmen, was du kriegst, ne? Ja, aber die fällt dann, glaube ich, auch aus.
Ich glaube, was ihnen nicht gefällt, das wird dann halt zur Perle.
Ah, sehr interessant.
Du bist so ein Romantiker, ey.
Aus dem, was ihnen nicht gefällt, machen die noch einen Schatz.
Also überleg mal, wie gut ist das von Tierern.
Genau, wie gut muss ihr Essen sein,
dass die Reste schon zur Perle werden.
Das ist ja ein grossartiges.
Sachen muss man da rein.
Das sind eigentlich die Tiere, denen es am besten geht, einfach, oder? Am aller, oder? Am allerbesten. Was müssen die denn machen gross in ihrem Leben? Die müssen auch nicht über ihr Tod entscheiden, weil irgendwann werden sie in den Strang gespült und sterben da, weil sie einfach ein Schwankspiel werden. Dann werden sie gegessen. So haben sie noch was Gutes getan beim Tod. Stell dir vor, du wirst in Zitrone ertränkt. Das ist auch krass. Das ist eine krasse Vorstellung. Dann wirst du so rausgepickt. Aber ist es denn immer so geil, sein Haus die ganze Zeit dabei zu haben? Ich stelle es mir gerade bei Schnecken echt awkward vor, wenn du bei so einer Party, bei einer schlechten Party eingeladen bist und denkst so, oh Leute, ich muss jetzt nach Hause. Na, geht nicht als Ausrede. Wenn sie mal Ungezieferplage oder so haben, dann können sie einfach... Vielleicht gehen. Oder Urlaub ist auch ganz schwierig. Aber deshalb sind sie immer sturmfrei. Die Gags fliegen heute. Man muss echt den Kettel... Das ist eigentlich das geile Nils-Bogelberg. Das ist die Nils-Bogelberg-Kanone. Wenn die mal losgeht, dann kann man nur in Deckung gehen. Einfach denken, oh, hör auf! Was sagt man denn da als Schnecke auf einer Party? Man kann nicht sagen, dass man nach Hause geht. Das ist eine super Feedline, ey. Was sagt die Schnecke auf der Party? Platz 10. Die früher gehen weh. Oh, oh, oh, ohh? Die Top 5! Ich gehe heute nicht mehr nach Hause. Das war Platz 5. Das war Platz 7. Also jetzt kommt Platz 4. Was sagt die Schnecke, die nach Hause will, weil sie sich nicht gut fühlt? Das war die beste Feetline auf Platz 5. Ich muss nach Hause, mein Haus brennt. Auf Platz 23 abgeschlagen, Florentis Beitrag. Letzte Woche auf Platz 30. Etwas weiter abgeschlagen. Oh shit. Wir ziehen das durch, ey, mir ist das egal, auf Platz 3. Der Dinge, die die Schnecke sagt, wenn sie früher nach Hause muss. Ich muss nach Hause, der Babysitter muss gleich wieder heim. Nils, komm, oder wird's bitte, lass auf einem Köcher. Tut mir leid, ich muss los, ich muss noch zum Klempner. Ich muss zum Klempner. Ja, die hat doch das Haus dabei. Das ist ziemlich... Ach so! Ja! Ja! Ja! Wie gut ist das, damit hat niemand mehr gerechnet. Das ist geil. Das ist das Beste. Hier war so ein Humor-Vakuum, was hier so... Ja, und dann Fum. Das ist so ein Humor-Vakuum, was plötzlich gefiltert hat. Aber jetzt kommt dann noch Platz eins, ne? Auf Platz zwei den besten rauszuhauen, ist halt taktisch unklug. Und jetzt kommt Platz eins. Und jetzt Stefan. Auf was ist noch? Auf Platz eins ist... Jetzt habt ihr euch wieder gefragt, was diese harte Schnitze bedeuten hatte. Wir wissen das nicht genau. Warum das Intro noch mal gespielt wurde. Was ich noch sagen wollte. Ich hab das... Nein, leg nicht ab. Nope, forget it. Ich hab rausgekommen, was ich dann nochmal. Was weiss, die Fiete noch mal. Was sagt die Schnecke, wenn sie vorzeitig die Party verlassen will? Platz 1. Schreibt's in die Kommentare, ihr könnt genauso mitmachen, immer per E-Mail, ist immer alles möglich. Ich bin kurz vor sich umgezogen. Ich habe den Herd angelassen, sowas? Ich hätte noch was auf dem Herd. Jetzt nicht mehr, ich habe geguckt, weil es geht sehr schnell. Ich glaube, die Kategorie war schon vor zehn Minuten. Aber wann müssen die Schneckenkinder eigentlich von zu Hause ausziehen? Wir melken dieses Thema die nächsten zwanzig Minuten, ob ihr wollt oder nicht, ist das egal. Aber stecken sie noch ein Comedy-Thema, weil sie ja sich selber fortpflanzen können. Also die brauchen halt, die können auch jedes Geschlecht annehmen. Wie pflanzen sie sich denn fort? Aber die können sich nicht mit sich selbst fortpflanzen. Das weiß ich nicht, das ist ein gefährlicher Halbwissen. Ich hoffe, dass nie eine Gegenfrage kommt. Die können sich nicht mit sich selbst fortpflanzen. Nein, nein, das habe ich mich jetzt gerade daran. Die teilen sich nicht einfach. Die teilen sich. Und sind die Mose, Mose, Viehmoose, Mayose, Mayonnaise, Gettmose, Mayonnaise, Mayonnaise, das sind die fünf Mosen. Das war unsere Top fünf. Da ist ja auch immer, wenn die sich teilen, ist immer die Frage, wer kriegt das Haus? Das ist einerseits unfair, weil es ausserhalb der Kategorie war, andererseits lass es durchgehen, weil der Gag nicht schlecht war. Nils Burgelberg, phantastisch, gefällt mir sehr gut. Das ist ein Punkt, wo man die Folge einfach abbrechen sollte. Aber ganz kurz nochmal zu deinem Podcast. Gäste, Liste, Geister, Mann. Ihr habt ja jetzt auch schon, also wer denkt ihr eigentlich, dass ihr seid? Ihr habt vier Folgen gemacht und macht jetzt schon irgendwie Merchandise, macht irgendwie so Jutebeutel, super Sachen. Leute, ihr wisst schon, dass man sich das erarbeiten muss. Nächste Woche Montag in Florian Köln. Bei Folge vier saßen wir noch in seinem verlausten Kinderzimmer da oben und zwischen seinen vollgewichsten Socken saßen wir da und haben uns hart jede Quant herausgeschnchnitzt. Es waren Boxershorts, waren voll gewichste Boxershorts.
Und ihr denkt, ihr habt es einfach schon geschafft, ihr seid schon da und könnt Geld verdienen. Nur weil ich Nils Bokelberg,
wie viele Twitter-Follower hast du? Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube 15, 16,
17.000 oder irgendwie sowas.
Tatsächlich, aber jeden einzeln
erarbeitet.
Das kenne ich nicht jetzt.
Ja, aber jetzt mal ernst, also was soll das?
Ne, wir haben ja gar keinen Merch, ich habe mir nur auf einer Kirmes so einen Beutel bedrucken lassen mit unserem Logo. Und so getan, als wenn das offizielles Merch wäre. Aber das kann im Grunde genommen jeder tun. So ein Ibersee hat ja auf die Idee gekommen. Ich meine, also wie kommt man auf so eine Idee, plötzlich so einen Podcast zu schreiben? Also lustigerweise war es so, dass vor, ich glaube sogar schon vor zwei Jahren hat Herm zu mir gesagt, wir müssen mal einen Podcast machen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja stimmt, wäre eigentlich ganz lustig. Und das ist so ein Ding, was man auf Partys sagt, nie macht, nie macht. Dann ist das so voll versandet und dann ein Jahr später ist Original Donnie zu mir gekommen und gesagt, wir müssten mal einen Podcast machen. Da habe ich gesagt, ja, ganz coole Idee und dann ist das so genauso versandet. Und irgendwann hat einer von beiden nochmal nachgefragt und dann habe ich gesagt, ja komm, lass uns das einfach zu drücken machen. Denkt euch da vielleicht eine bessere Geschichte aus. Also jetzt nichts gegen die Geschichte, die war richtig geil, aber vielleicht. Aber ist Donnie vielleicht der geilste Name der Welt? Ja, vor allem, aber ich finde es auch gut, mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit er den Namen Herm benutzt. Ja, dann kam Herm auf mich zu, so wie der... Dann kam Herm und Donny auf mich zu. Diese Geschichte ist nicht echt, die heißen nicht so. Obwohl es das einzige an der Geschichte war, was wahrscheinlich wahr ist. Also ich will nicht so heißen. Aber... Ja, aber das ist schon... Also ihr macht schon... Ja, das ist keine spannende... Kannst du bitte ein bisschen näher ins Mikrofon gehen? Mich macht das echt wahnsinnig. Ja, es ist keine... Du hast so geile Gags raus und die Angst, dass die nicht... Du hast gesagt, ich soll so, hier, King's Speech. So hast du gesagt. Ja, soll ich. Aber so nahm ich die ganze Zeit. Ja, bist du Colin Firth oder nicht? Was war denn das überhaupt für ein Ding? Das sieht man nicht. Ja, ja, du hast ja... Aber das meine ich Folge vier. Du hast mir mit zwei Fingern, du hast mir mit zwei Händen gezeigt, wie ich an dem Mikro sitzen soll. Ja, Folge vier. Zände Abstand. Nils. Nehmt ihr auch so auf eigentlich in dieser Art Aufnahmesituation? Oder habt ihr so ein professionelles Toolstudio? Nehmt ihr auch in einer Aufnahmesituation auf, ist die Frage von dem Journalismus 80 von 62 Punkten, Stefan Titzel? Sieben und fucking 90 Punkte. Nehmt ihr auch in einer Aufnahme? Also es war eine Journalismusprüfung. Möchte ich jetzt nicht drauf eingehen. Ne, immer am Esstisch. Guck mal, wie auf dem Bild, was ihr hier habt, als Anzeigebild. Sehr gut. Hätte man auch drauf kommen können. Aber Jutebeutel ist wieder Einstiegsmerge. Wo soll es langfristig hingehen? Das ist jetzt deine Frage. Die Warnweste, der Fahrradwimpel, wo soll es hingehen? Lass uns mal träumen. Kugelschreiber. Lass uns mal träumen. Lass uns mal träumen einfach. Irgendwie Merch. Faden. Man kann gar nicht genug Merch haben, finde ich. Man kann eigentlich, wir wollten mal T-Shirts machen, mit dem folgenden Aufdrücken, die Flurin, unsere Top-5-Aufdruck-Ideen. Wer hat nicht immer Ideen, aber ich weiß auch nicht mehr, wie sie waren. Zunächst mal. Keep it das. Weil Joyce Ilk hat Keep it Joyce Ilk als ... Auf dem T-Shirt stehen. Komm, wenn ihr einen Wortwitz machen wollt, dann versuchts doch wenigstens. Aber Keep it Joyce Ilk, mach doch einfach Keep it, Gäste lässt die Geisterbahn. Hä, wie sagt die, aber ich verstehe den Gäste auch nicht. Das ist ja der Punkt. Du bist da ein Crush auf sie, du kannst uns das, sag ich, mal erklären. Meine Vision ist durch Liebe geblendet, ich kann dir das gerade nicht erklären. Liebe kann man nicht erklären, Nils. Ja, aber dann hat man mehr Verständnis und kann das dann anderen besser erklären, was diese Menschen sagen wollen. Liebe kann ja auch ein Transmitter sein. Also Liebe ist eine Sprache, möchtest du damit sagen. Ja, Liebe kann eine Sprache sein. Ich habe massive Grammatikprobleme. Liebe kann auch die Übersetzung sein. Geht da ein bisschen näher drauf ein. Liebe ist die Übersetzung. Das finde ich ein schöner Satz. Liebe ist die Übersetzung. Nee, ich würde im Konjunktiv bleiben und sagen, Liebe kann die Übersetzung sein. Wir haben den Faden verloren. Wollen wir nochmal angefangen mit dem Thema? Wir haben gerade einen ganz schönen Moment geschaffen. Liebe ist ja universell. Liebe ist ja interdisziplinär. Liebe ist zwischen Menschen jeglichen Geschlechts, jeglichen Alters möglich. Aber ist Liebe schon transzendental? Ja. So, genau das, was ich erreichen wollte. Das Gespräch beendet. Die gute alte Rhetorische Frage. Die gute alte Ja-Nein-Frage. Tja, kein Ja und kein Nein passt, weil man nicht weiss, was das bedeutet. Ich wollte eben kurz darauf eingehen. Du hast eben gesagt, dass man Dinge macht, die bewusst schlecht sind, um sich selber zu strafen. Bei Filmen habe ich das total. Und da kann bestimmt der Nils, Moderationsüberleitung, Landschule.
Da kann bestimmt der Nils was dazu sagen.
Was dazu sagen, weil er ja auch Filme rezensiert
bei YouTube, habe ich gesehen.
Ja, richtig.
Unbelievable.
Da habe ich das wirklich.
Ich gehe gerne in Filme, wo ich weiß, sie werden schlecht,
um mich darüber lustig zu machen.
Man kann die ja auch ironisch
rezipieren. Ja, das ist interessant.
Ich habe ja, mein Ansatz beim Filme gucken ist ja der, ich will erst mal rausfinden, was an dem Film gut ist. Also auch wenn das irgendein Trash-Film ist, dann gucke ich den so, dass ich erst mal versuche herauszufinden, was ich daran gut finden könnte. Ja, genau. Oder was ich daran honorieren kann oder was ich daran ernsthaft gut finde. Mit diesem Ansatz habe ich zum Beispiel auch Daniel der Zauberer geguckt, mit Daniel Kübelberg, der halt ein ganz unmöglicher Film ist. Großartiger Film, fantastischer Film. Ja, der ist fantastisch. Bis zum dritten Akt. Der ist halt eigentlich unmöglich, aber der ist so, ich habe noch nie einen Film gesehen, der mehr deutsch war, der so dieses Deutschsein besser ausgestellt hat als der. Das war nicht ganz freiwillig, aber das schafft der. Ich glaube, da haben wir schon mal drüber geredet. Daniel Zauberer ist mal ein Film, der auf der IMDB-Bewertungsliste an allerletzter Stelle stand. Man konnte bei IMDB so einsehen, die internationalen, der allerschlechteste Film aller Zeiten. Mittlerweile ist es, glaube ich, ein anderer. Mittlerweile ist er, glaube ich, auf Platz minus drei oder sowas. Mittlerweile ist es doch Jurassic World gewünscht. Tatsächlich ist es doch mein Film aus der achten Klasse geworden.
Und tatsächlich habe ich den mal in einem Edeka
gefunden für 1,50 Euro und habe mir den
sofort geholt und ist ein super geiler Film.
Und da fällt es einem eigentlich auf,
wie viel, also Filme sind ja oft nach einem
relativ ähnlichen Muster gemacht, man kann ja immer so sagen,
keine Ahnung, Jaws ist im Grunde derselbe
Film wie Batman, weil bla bla bla
die gleich schon mal. Ja, weil immer jemand ein Hindernis
überwissen muss, um jemand anderes zu werden. Ja, die Eltenreise, die verschiedenen Punkte Blablum und so. Aber ich finde gerade bei einem Film, Daniel Zauberer, fällt es einem auf, wie es einem auffällt, wenn sowas mal fehlt. Wenn also überhaupt kein dramatischer Bogen ist, wenn man nicht weiss, wo man gerade in der Geschichte ist. Das ist genauso wie Höflichkeitsfloskeln, die man einfach so sagt jeden Tag, aber sobald sie mal jemanden weglässt, dann fällt es sofort auf, wie du hast dich gerade nicht bedankt, dann fällt es einem auf. Und deswegen finde ich da einen Zauberer so interessant, weil da kann man mal wirklich sehen, wie man wirklich ein fünfjähriges Kind einen Film machen würde. Aber jetzt noch mal ganz kurz. Aber ich glaube schon, dass die eine Heldenreise erzählen wollten. Also sie sind daran gescheitert, aber das war die Intention, auf jeden Fall eine Heldenreise zu erzählen. Ja klar, aber ich finde auch so vom Aufbau von der Struktur, auch das Ende kommt relativ überraschend und man denkt immer, in der Hälfte des Films schon, denkt man schon, jetzt müsste der Film eigentlich vorbei sein. Man weiss nie die Spannung. Es kam sehr überraschend mit dem Satz, weil plötzlich die Credits da. Man weiss gar nicht, war das Schnittschwelle. Es waren Schnittschwelle, aber es kam sehr überraschend. Es gibt ja die Spannungsmaus. Mein Gott, die Spannungsmaus baut sich langsam auf und hinten und dann kommt noch der Schwanz raus. Das ist der Sequel. Sequel-Kritik vielleicht an der Stelle. Nee, aber tatsächlich, du findest es einen sehr schönen Ansatz, dass du sagst, du willst bei jedem Film, weil es gibt ja viel Zynismus heutzutage und das finde ich sehr gut, dass jemand dann in die Kinosäle sich setzt und sagt, hey, ich bin jetzt nicht so einer, der sagt, Film überzeugt mich, sondern der sagt, hey, ich versuche dem was abzugewinnen und ich versuche die Perlen rauszuarbeiten. Was hast du denn Gutes in Kartoffelsalat gefunden? Hast du den gesehen? Das war aber eine lange Einheit. Hast du bei Wyatt nicht sogar eine Kolumne? Hast du bei Wyatt nicht sogar darüber geschrieben? Ich habe auch über Kartoffelsalat geschrieben. Ja, Recherche 80 von Ja, das ist ein schwieriger Fall, weil ich glaube, das Problem von Kartoffelsalat ist, dass der sich in seiner Albernheit für relativ clever hält. Und das haut halt eigentlich fast nie hin. Ich glaube, man muss sich entscheiden, entweder albern sein zu wollen oder clever, aber nicht albern sein mit dem Gedanken, besonders clever zu sein. Das ist immer ganz schwer. Ist das nicht das generelle Problem von YouTubern? Habe ich mal das Gefühl. Also die haben ja ein relativ schlechtes Image, so in manchen Kreisen. Und wo man auch denkt, hätten die das, wenn die selbstironischer sich selber rangehen würden? Ja, die sind natürlich auch super jung. Also Selbstironie ist ja was, was wahnsinnig schwerfällt, was man sich, glaube ich, auch echt erst so angewöhnen muss und anlernen muss. Das bringt, glaube ich, keiner von zu Hause mit, Selbstironie. Das tut ja auch ein bisschen weh. Da muss man sich selber geißen wollen. Ja, man muss auch lernen, dass Schmerz auch Katharsis ist und dass Eitelkeit auch wehtun muss. Ah, Nils Buckelberg, dass Eitelkeit auch wehtun. Du hast ja immer noch nicht gesagt, was du gut an Kartoffelser hat findest, deswegen möchte ich dich darauf festnageln, das ist nämlich auch schon ein Gespräch. Willkommen zurück zur Philosophiestunde, zur Philosophies Sternstunde. Was fand ich denn gut an Kartoffelsalat? Übrigens ganz kurzer Newsflash. Jeder, der über den Film Kartoffelsalat spricht und dabei einen Witz macht, der das Wortspiel involviert, dass Kartoffelsalat ja nicht nur der Name eines Films ist, sondern tatsächlich auch eine Mahlzeit. Jeder, der das macht, mit jedem Mahl, hat Frischtauge gewonnen. Stirbt ein Kind in Afrika. Wenn ihr das macht, hat Frischtauge gewonnen. Seid euch dessen bewusst. Auch wenn ihr den Film hasst und ihr macht diesen Gag, hat Frischtauge gewonnen. Was für ein Gag denn jetzt? Ich habe den Gag auch noch nie gehört, ehrlich gesagt. Ich verstehe den gar nicht. Dass Kartoffelsalat nicht nur der Name eines Films, sondern auch die Bezeichnung für ein typisch deutsches Essensgericht ist. Aber wo ist denn da der Witz? Ja, das ist doch... Aber was ist denn... Aber warum sollte man das denn schreiben? Ja, verstehe ich auch nicht. Was ist denn hier los? Kartoffelsalat! Ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Spürst du das? Der ganze Humor, der eben noch in diesem Raum war, ist gerade irgendwo verschwunden. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was da, ich verstehe den Witz nicht, weil, hä? Kartoffelsalat ist sowohl der Name eines Films als auch die Bezeichnung für ein traditionelles deutsches Gericht. Ja, und das ist ja richtig. Und jeder, der über diesen Film redet und auf diesen Fakt hinweist und sowas sagt wie, na, wie hat euch der Film denn geschmeckt? Oder es gibt ja viele verschiedene Rezepte für Kartoffelsalat oder irgendwas mit Essig oder mit Mayonnaise. Jeder, der diesen, es ist unglaublich lange jetzt für diesen Punkt, aber wenn ich mich achtmal fragt. Nein, das ist nämlich das, so gewinnen die Leute nämlich. Warum gewinnen, was gewinnen die denn dann? Ich will in einer Welt leben, in der auch Kritiker kritisch über diesen Film reden und einfach ignorieren, dass dieser Film einen beschissenen Titel hat. Ja, aber da, ich bin als, also in meiner Kritik bin ich überhaupt nicht auf den Titel eingegangen. Ja, ich weiss, deswegen, das war ein Lob. Im Endeffekt wollte ich sagen, ich brauchte deine Kritik sehr. Das ist halt so ein Quatschtitel, mein Gott, das soll ich ja schon nennen, weil letzten Endes ist das natürlich auch, wir finden die natürlich alle lustig.
Ja, ich fand das, also was ich zum Beispiel schwierig fand bei Kartoffelsalat, wobei ich soll jetzt die Sachen sagen, die mir gefallen haben, aber ich sage noch kurz etwas, was ich schwierig fand. Du kannst sagen, was du willst übrigens. Im Trailer. Im Trailer stand irgendwie dann so, das ist der beschissenste Film, den ich jemals gesehen habe, als Zitate von Hatern, die so den Film noch nie gesehen haben. und das ist was, was in Deutschland
ganz oft passiert, was so in
Humorgeschichten, was mir mega auf den Keks geht
so Kritik vorwegnehmen, damit die dann nicht mehr greift. Das finde ich super albern, das hat mich mega aufgeregt beim Kartoffelsalat-Trailer. Also so zu glauben, dass man damit durchkommt, das hat mich dann schon so ein bisschen negativer dem Film gegenüber eingestellt, als es grundsätzlich war. Also du meinst, dass man sagt, von wegen, wir wissen, dass der Film scheiße ist
oder im Sinne von Selbstironie zeigen,
im Sinne von, ja, selbst wenn
ihr uns hassen würdet, wir würden gut damit klarkommen.
Oder würdest du sagen, damit versucht man
die Herangehensweise der Zuschauer zu manipulieren,
dass man sagt, ja, wir wissen, dass er nicht so geil ist?
Nee, nee, ich glaube, dass sie den supergeil finden.
Also ich hoffe es, weil ich fände es
schlimm, wenn Menschen Filme machen, die sie nicht geil finden.
Aber ich glaube, dass man versucht, Kritik so vorwegzunehmen und schonände es schlimm, wenn Menschen Filme machen, die sie nicht geil finden. Aber ich glaube,
dass man versucht, Kritik so vorwegzunehmen
und schon im Vorfeld so lächerlich zu machen,
dass wenn dann wirkliche Kritik
kommt, die nicht mehr greift, weil man sich vorher schon
drüber lustig gemacht hat, weil man dann sagen kann so
siehste, genau das haben wir kommen sehen, dass ihr das
scheiße findet. Und dass man dann vielleicht
auch tatsächlich begründete Kritik als
Hatin oder der Hater,
damit die Kritiker eigentlich schon seine Waffen nehmen. Hitler hätte eigentlich viel richtig machen können, wenn er vorher gesagt hätte, gut, ihr werdet jetzt so scheiße finden, was ich jetzt mache, aber danach hätte er nie mehr was sagen können. Alle Kritiker werden abgeprallt an dieser Wand. Oder halt im Nachhinein Just Kidding sagen. Das ist so einfach. Wenn einfach bei den Nürnberger Prozessen sagen Just Kidding und er wird fein aus. Es war ein Scherz. Aber ganz kurz. Und wenn ihr das nicht glaubt, dann seid ihr verdammte humorlose Arschlöcher. Und mal ganz kurz zum Thema Zweiter Weltkrieg. Das ist unser Thema. Glaubt ihr nicht, also, dass nach dem Holocaust sich die Juden zusammengesetzt haben und gesagt haben, also man versucht ja auch, kritikfähig zu sein. Und einfach zu sagen, was haben wir da eigentlich immer uns? Also klar, natürlich war der Holocaust übertrieben, sechs Millionen von uns umzubringen ist too much, da sind wir uns alle einig. Aber lass uns doch mal ganz nüchtern an die Sache rangehen. Ist da nicht vielleicht ein Kern Wahrheit drin? Glaubst du nicht, dass es auch selbstkritische Juden gab, die gesagt haben, jetzt mal ganz objektiv an die Sache herangetreten? Haben die nicht vielleicht ein bisschen Recht? Nee, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das gab es nicht. Wir haben ja schon mal drüber gesprochen. Holocaust ist kein Gag-Thema. Das ist wirklich... Und jetzt noch mal zum Thema... Ich fand es gut, dass Otto mit Karton-Hunterland. Wenn dem Schwein da das Bein abgeschnitten wird, denkt er sich nicht auch ein bisschen, ja, vielleicht hätte ich einfach die Kappe halten sollen mit der Nacht. Das Schwein? Vielleicht hätte ich es auch lassen sollen. Wir haben da schon mal drüber gesprochen, tatsächlich. Fällt mir gerade auf. Wirklich? So Epiphanie. Jetzt haben wir wirklich schon mal... Epiphanie? Epiphanie? Epiphanie. Ich kenne das Wort nicht. Ich habe es nur mal gelesen. Warte, ich habe es noch nie gesprochen. Epiphany gibt es im Englischen das Wort. Im Englischen, ja. Aber es gibt es auch im Simpsons Film, die das übersetzt. Die Epiphanie. Ich zitiere aus Simpsons Filmen. Ja, ich habe es gesagt. Was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Wir haben wirklich mal über Massentierhaltung gesprochen. Und da haben wir gesagt, dass die Tiere ja gar nicht wissen, dass es ein besseres Leben gibt.
Und dass sie deshalb vielleicht es gar nicht so schlecht sind. Ah, du meinst das sozusagen wie in einer Matrix, leben wir auch alle in Massen-Tier-Haltung. Aber da will ich nicht als solche erkennen. Zum Beispiel, dass bei Hühnern, damit die zwei Eier am Tag legen, haben die nur sechs Stunden Tage in dem Sinne. Also sechs Stunden Tage, sechs Stunden Nacht, sechs Stunden Tage. Man macht das Licht auch. Dann denken die, es wären zwei Tage und die wissen ja gar nicht, dass ein Tag wirklich zwölf Stunden hat, ein richtiger Tag. Und vielleicht haben die das so akzeptiert und das ihr Leben genommen. Vielleicht sind wir auch tatsächlich in der Massentierhaltung befindlich und wissen das gar nicht. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zur Philosophiestunde mit Frongebild, Stefanise und Jens Buckelberg. Ja, das ist ja eh die Frage, wie, warum, wie, wer, wann angefangen hat, das so zu zählen. So Einheiten, Tag und Wochen und Monate und so ein Scheiss. Dass man gesagt hat, ein Erdlauf ist ein Tag. Genau. Das ist ja eine crazy Idee, oder? Da hätte man ja auch was ganz anderes sagen können. Das ist so wahnsinnig, einmal dunkel, hell ist ein Tag. Wer bist du denn? Ja, es ist mir nicht so ein Wächerliches. Man hätte ja auch sein können, dass die erste Nacht so eine Art Mittagspause ist und dann der Tag nochmal losgeht.
Bist du nicht der Typ, der gesagt hat, wir sollen mit den Beinen laufen?
Hallo, warst nicht du das auch?
Oder? Das warst du, ich sehe das doch, dass du das warst.
Es hätte doch sein können, dass das dann so zwei Tage ein Tag gewesen wäre.
Ich habe so, wie du es schon mal gesagt, wenn wir anfangen, auf anderen Planeten irgendwann zu leben, gibt es riesige Probleme, weil dann gibt es andere Tagesläufe. Und wenn du sagst, gestern, aber du telefonierst mit einem Freund auf dem Uranus, wo der Tag irgendwie 30 Sekunden ist, dann sagt er, wie gestern, ich muss gleich ins Bett. Du kannst vor allem telefonieren. Glaubst du, dass wir dann noch telefonieren? Das geht ja auch gar nicht. Das ist, weißt du, dass der Journalist, der pickt sich die Details aus. Konfrontiert dich mit den offensichtlich falschen Details. Wie konfrontiert damit meine Geschichte? Das finde ich so geil. Du kannst ja nicht telefonieren. Nee, ich frage mich das tatsächlich, weil ich meine, heute schreiben wir das schon fast. Also ich maile lieber, als zu telefonieren. Ich auch. Das macht dann ja auch noch viel mehr Sinn, interplanetar sich zu mailen. Ich habe bei Mails auch mittlerweile alle Hemmschwellen abgesetzt. Ich finde, du bist echt ein ganz interessanter... Ich finde es gut, dass du einfach so gut verstehst. Ich finde, du hast in den letzten 30 Minuten mich zu einem ganz reisen, saftigen, männlichen Menschen. Nenn das nicht ernst. Ganz kurz, können wir mal ein bisschen über dein Beauty-Geheimnis sprechen? Ja, unbedingt. Wie schaffst du es, so rank und schlank zu bleiben? Gibt's da, also was ist das, die Casa Bokelberg, möchte ich jetzt einfach mal aufmachen. Ernährung ist ein ganz großes Thema, Ernährung ist ein ganz großes Thema und Bewegung. Was ist denn so? Ja, was halt gerade so rumliegt, ne? Und ich gehe dahin, wo ich muss.
Also bist du quasi wie so eine Muschel, die eigentlich war. Ich bin eigentlich wie eine Muschel.
Was soll in die Reihenzeit?
Das ist die Muscheltransformation.
Schöne Autobiografie-Titel.
Ich gehe dahin, wo ich muss.
Das hat so eine romantische Getriebenheit.
Es ist grammatikalisch Fall.
Das ist egal.
Nach Kollegah biete ich jetzt die Muscheltransformation an.
Nach der Boss-Transformation und I make you sexy.com und so.
Und Daniel Animati hat jetzt auch so ein Rättenprogramm. Animatiati! Oder Amimati. War das ein Gag oder ein Versprecher? Der hatte jetzt auch so ein Fitnessprogramm. Und ich jetzt eben auch. Geil. Prinzip Muschel. Glaubst du, das ist eine Diät? Glaubst du, wenn man wieder abnehmen, wenn man alles essen wird, was dann vorgesetzt wird einfach? Dass irgendwann Freunde ankommen, die das nicht verarschen wollen und denen, ja, oh, da muss man jetzt halt vier Dosen Booster trinken, die Millionen Zucker haben. Oder würde man abnehmen tatsächlich, wenn alles das Essen würde, wie eine Muschel quasi, was in einen reintreibt. So mit offenem Mund durch die Innenstadt läuft und einfach mal guckt, was passiert, was hängen bleibt. Ja, man muss alles essen halt. Mit so einem Kescher. Ich habe es letztens für mich entdeckt, weil ich ja tatsächlich versucht habe, abzhmen, und ich hasse abnehmen und es funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Es hat eine Weile dann ganz gut funktioniert, aber irgendwann denkst du, gut, ich habe halt vielleicht abgenommen, aber ich bin halt einfach nicht mehr glücklich. So, ich ernähre mich jetzt vielleicht gesund, aber ich habe einfach keine Lebensfreude mehr. So, dann denkst du mir, ja gut, ist es das wert? Und jeder, der erzählt... Man sieht gerade nicht, er hat total verweinte Augen. Jorann, er hat unfassbar verweinte Augen. Das ist der Süßstoff, der mir aus den Augen ge gewählt. Das Stevia. Ja, ja, genau. Du riechst so ganz unangenehm noch Bio irgendwie. Aber ja, es ist furchtbar. Und deswegen versuche ich jetzt eine neue Diät zu entwickeln, einfach die Cheat-Diät, wo man nicht merkt, dass man abnimmt und wo man zum Beispiel alles, was man normalerweise essen würde, einfach durch solchen Chemieschwachsinn ersetzt. Wie zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt entwickelt, ich esse extrem viel Wackelpudding, zubereitet mit Süßstoff statt mit Zucker. Du kannst dir diese Päckchen kaufen und einfach selber zubereiten und da musst du ja eigentlich normalerweise Zucker hinzufügen, stattdessen einfach Süßstoff, das Ding hat null Kalorien und du kannst am Tag einfach drei Kilo Wackelpudding essen, das ist einfach null Kalorien, einfach nichts, aber du isst trotzdem Wackelpudding und dein Körper rastet zwar innerlich aus, dann denkst du dir, was ist denn hier los? Hier kommt die ganze Zeit dieser Scheiss rein. Töte mich! Dieser Scheiss rein und wir versuchen, das abzubauen. Als würdest du dir von Amazon immer leere Kisten bestellen. Da kommen immer Sachen an und du denkst dir, ja Leute, irgendwann wird es auch leben. Was soll das, was soll ich damit? Aber das funktioniert und das versuche ich zu... Du musst doch nicht so Vitamintabletten nehmen, um das irgendwie auszugleichen, deinen Nährstoffhaushalt. Aber lass doch den Zuckergast her und kippt um die Süssung. Ja, aber dann schmeckt es furchtbar. Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, tatsächlich, als Kind. Weil das ist tatsächlich eine der grössten Enttäuschungen meines Lebens. Da ist die Mutter mal weg irgendwie, Vietnam oder irgendwie sowas, und du hast das Wochenende frei und denkst dir... Im Krieg natürlich. Im Krieg, ja. Und denkst dir, okay, geil, lass mal richtig die Sau raus, Rock'n'Roll, willst den Wackelpudding machen, musst dann aber die Nacht warten, weil er in dem Kühlschrank sein muss und merkst dann, du hast den Zucker vergessen. Und dann schmeckt es furchtbar und dann versuchst du noch Zucker oben drüber zu streuen. Ja, das ist ganz schön. Dann merkst du, das ist echt ätzend. Ja, das ist super. Dann wirfst du dieses Wackelpudding und dann wabbelt der so im Kompost herum. Das Observation bekommt man nicht, weil schon bei jedem passiert ist, bestimmt. Ja, weiss ich, fick dich doch. Hast du den Wackelpudding wirklich in Kompost geworfen? Ja. Wo wirft man den Wackelpudding hin? Wahrscheinlich hört der einen Kompost, aber es ist schon sehr gut erzogen. Aber wird Wackelpudding irgendwann schlecht einfach, wenn man dann einfach, also er schmilzt irgendwann, wenn man den nicht kühlt, aber wenn man den gekühlt im Kühlschrank stehen lässt, müsste der sich eigentlich unendlich lange halten. Stell dir mal vor, man will jetzt noch einen Wackelpudding von Tudelig Ammon oder so finden. Das wäre krass. Einfach so ein Löffel Wackelpudding. Wer dürfte den essen? Oder? Ja, erstmal wer will den essen. Ja. Und dann wer da? Sind die Pyramiden vielleicht doch nicht aus Wackelpudding entstanden. Weiß man nicht, gehärtetes Wackelpudding, versteinert, kleiner Denkanstoss. Weiß ja keiner, wie die da gebaut wurden. Das weiss echt noch niemand. Das sind diese Geheimnisse der Menschheit, die einen wahnsinnig machen, finde ich. Was treibt dich eigentlich um? Welche Geheimnisse der Welt? Finde ich das interessant? Auch andere Planeten finden das spannend. Ja, ja. Hast du dir schon mal so einen Stift so hinters Ohr geklemmt? Ja. Ich noch nicht, ich dachte. Jetzt wird jetzt weiter Pulle-Booster aufgemacht. Das war jetzt so ein Mysterium der Welt, das habe ich noch nie gemacht und ich glaube, ich werde es auch nie machen. So einen Stift so in das Ohr stecken. Doch, wenn man so was, wenn man was an die Wand bohrt oder so, dann so den Bleistift in das Ohr. Was hast du das letzte Mal an die Wand gebohrt? Einen Spiegel. Das ist die beste Fall, die ich jemals im Interview gehört habe. Oder so den Telefonhörer so mit der Schulter einklemmen, habe ich noch nie gemacht. Das habe ich auch mal gemacht, aber jetzt beim Handy eigentlich nicht mehr. Aber jetzt ist es für mich so der Punkt gekommen, wo ich mir denke, wenn ich es mal mache, dann ist es bestimmt total nervös. Irgendwie so das erste Mal, so wie wird es sein, irgendwie kriege ich es auf die Reihe, irgendwie lasse ich es fallen, irgendwie. Und du willst eine halbe Stunde nur darüber sprechen. Dadurch, dass man sich das bewusst macht, dass man es noch nie gemacht hat, wird es das erste Mal einfach so wahnsinnig relevant plötzlich. Und dadurch kann man es gar nicht mehr natürlich genießen. Es ist ja im Grunde genommen Anachronismus. Was ist das Buchstabieren? So grosse Buchstabieren? Anachronismus? Nee, es war nur ein Gegner. Es war auch einfach so Buchst ja so, Buchstabier mal Baum. Anachronismus ist doch... So klingt Florentin auch in meinen Ohren, das ist witzig. Nee, aber... So werde ich aber häufig mit dir. Hier mal den Baum nennen. Nee, aber es gibt ja diese Hörer, die sich so aufdrängen, zwischen Uhr und Schulter geklemmt zu werden. Die werden gar nicht mehr, die gibt es gar nicht mehr, die werden gar nicht mehr benutzt. Also es waren ja hauptsächlich so Festnetztelefonen. Diese grossen Plastikhörer meinst du, ne? Da habe ich neulich gesehen, dass man die irgendwie ans Handy, als Adapter, an den Nostalgiegründen. Stimmt, das gibt es echt schon ähnlich. Wir können jetzt aber auch unseren Gast ein bisschen eingehen. Wir können jetzt auch unseren Gast ein bisschen eingehen. Wir können jetzt auch noch ein bisschen eingehen. Wir können jetzt auch noch ein bisschen eingehen. Wir können jetzt auch noch ein bisschen eingehen. Wir können jetzt auch noch ein bisschen eingehen. Weißt du dann, dass ich meinen Gast einbeziehen will. Ja, aber dann sag nicht, das gibt es jetzt auch. Dann sag das seit fünf Jahren. Habe ich aber gerade erst mal entdenkt. Bei Norma. Bei Norma. Norma. Sagst du noch mal, Norma? Norma. Wo würdest du sagen, sind Nils grösste Schwächen in der Aussprache? Ich finde, er macht das schon sehr gut. Vielen Dank. Norma. Aber wie gesagt, man kann beim R schon sehr viel wettmachen. Was würdest du denn sagen, was die grössten Schwächen in Aussprache sind? Genau, du hast es nämlich so noch schon angefangen. Die hohen Töne. Die hohen Töne? Triffst du oft nicht, oft so ein bisschen daneben. Aber jetzt mal ganz klar, was ist eigentlich dein Job? Also du bist ja halt so ein Medientyp, wo man immer so denkt, ah ja, der Medientyp, und den kann jeder einordnen. Und wenn es heißt, oh, es gibt eine neue Panel-Show auf RTL, moderiert von Nils Bokeberg, sagen alle, ja, okay, passt. Aber was machst du so den ganzen Tag so? Also du hast ja bestimmt ganz viele Jobs. Aber wie würdest du dich einordnen beruflich? Ja, das ist immer schwierig. Genau die Frage wollte ich vermeiden eigentlich, weil das ist also die klassische Frage, ist die da Deppstät. Also auch wenn jede Frage reinzugreifen, dass die Scheisse ist, nur weil du weißt nicht, nur 93 Punkte hast in Moderation, wirst du nicht an mir auslassen.
Das ist schwierig, ich weiss das immer nie.
Ich sage immer, Autor ist...
Also du hast einen YouTube-Kanal, du hast einen Podcast, du schreibst zu Wired.
Aber die ersten beiden Sachen sind ja moderativ.
Weiter, weiter, weiter.
Für das Wired-Schreiben ist es journalistisch, meinungsjournalistisch.
Für das Wired-Schreiben ist Schreiben, ich habe ja auch ein Buch geschrieben und so.
Also ich würde sagen, Moderator und Autor ist so das, was ich immer sage.
Früher habe ich noch DJ dazu gesagt, aber auflegen triefe ich überhaupt nicht mehr. Aber auf Tinder würdest du erst Autor schreiben, dann Moderator, oder? Bei Tinder würdest du auch Sänger, glaube ich, noch aufschreiben, oder? Das ist eine gute Frage. Nee, bei Tinder würde ich nicht Sänger schreiben. Meine Biografie auf Tinder war... Muschel, hauptsächlich Muschel. Muschel, das fand ich wahnsinnig lustig. Also weil du mit vollem Mund sprichst, oder? Nein, ich fand es mega lustig, ja. Bei mir steht einfach nur vier Zentimeter pure Lust. Also so ein Peniswitz. Sozusagen. Ja. Das ist interessant. Das ist ein Icebreaker. Das ist ein Icebreaker. Meine Leute, ey. Mir ist auf Tinder aufgefallen, dass es eine extrem hohe Dichte hatte an so TCM-Jacken. Die Frauen tragen da alle so Chibo-Jacken, die mir gezeigt wurden. Und Quesua. Und was? Entschuldigung. Ich habe es nicht richtig gehört. Quesua. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das ausspreche. Das ist so eine Sportmarke, die immer Wanderer tragen. So wie Jack Wolfskin, wo man sagt, das tragen nur Lehrer. Entschuldigung, es ist ein Wörter von Hoft, bitte kennt das.
Ach ja, Quaschua.
So, ja, diese eine Marke. Ah, Quaschua.
Das nuschelt man doch, glaube ich.
Die Herrscher nuschelt das.
Nein, so Tartonka.
Nein, aber auch interessant.
Danke.
Gut, dass du mir die, aber auch interessant.
Ich weiß nicht, wie, was, wie, Quaschua heißt das?
Das ist so eine Marke, die tragen hauptsächlich Wanderer. Und so die Leute wie Bear Grylls-Leute, die halt in Bergen wandern gehen und wilde Tiere jagen. Du machst heute eine ganz schlechte 94. Du bist heute echt unter 90. Es ist 94, aber ich steige heute. Ja, das ist wirklich so. Und Jack Wolfskin ist, glaube ich, auch so ein Brennpunkt eigentlich. Viele Lehrer sagt man auch immer. Wir haben damals gesagt, dass Lehrer immer Jack Wolfskin tragen.
Aber lass mich da mal ganz kurz, wo bist du denn Autor zum Beispiel jetzt?
Naja, wenn ich eben meine Wired-Kolumnen schreibe und ich habe auch ein Buch geschrieben und fange jetzt gerade an, so das nächste Buch zu planen.
Ich wusste, dass er ein Buch geschrieben hat.
Wie bitte?
Was ist das für ein Buch?
Ich habe ein Buch geschrieben über Lieblingsmusik.
Das heisst endlich mit Musik.
Wie schreibt man ein Buch?
Ja, da war das relativ einfach, weil da musste ich einfach nur Texte über Lieblingsbands, Lieblingsmusik schreiben oder mir Texte einfallen lassen, die irgendwie mit Musik, die ich mag, zu tun haben. Die Rolling Stones-Liste, die besten fünfzig Songs, einfach aus einer Seite, an der vier Seite. Ja, es war im Grunde genommen so, als würde ich persönlich eine komplette Ausgabe Rolling Stone machen dürfen. So bin ich da quasi rangegangen und habe versucht, so, keine Ahnung, die fünf besten Saxophon-Solos des Pop habe ich geschrieben, so eine Liste, aber dann auch so einen Text nur über Michael Jackson oder nur über Kurt Cobain und wie toll ich den fand. Also Musik ist ein wichtiger Teil unseres Lebens, würde es so sagen. Absolut. Ist wirklich Musik so etwas wie eine Sprache? Halt mir die Fresse kurz. Würdest du vielleicht, ich meine, wie das eine Sprache ist. Aber würdest du gerne die Wyatt-Kolumne gegen eine Rolling Stone-Kolumne tauschen vielleicht? Also würdest du lieber, ich meine nicht, dass du jetzt irgendwie dein Arbeitgeber irgendwie diffamieren musst, aber interessant. Da habe ich mir gar nicht übernachgebracht. Also da ich ja auch tatsächlich viele Filme gucke und Serien und so, fällt mir die Wyatt-Kolumne natürlich auch nicht besonders schwer, vor allem weil ich da auch schreiben kann, was ich will irgendwie und das ist ja eigentlich immer ganz angekommen. Wassen die dich machen, was du willst? Ja, wobei im letzten Text ist mir tatsächlich dann später aufgefallen, weil ich schreibe dann immer einen Text und dann schicke ich den hin und dann ist es mir auch egal sozusagen. Und das letzte Mal ist mir aber aufgefallen, dass die zwei Sätze am Ende meines Textes rausgestrichen haben, weil sie vielleicht nicht so elegant waren oder so. Auf jeden Fall schien dann etwas, was ich gesagt habe, eher eine Kritik zu sein, obwohl diese zwei Sätze das noch relativiert haben. Und die haben die dann rausgestrichen. Das fand ich ja mir ganz geil. Diese Arschlöcher. Naja, so ist das halt. Die haben auch deine Jurassic World-Kolumne übertitelt mit Macht dir Spaß, was ja eigentlich nur in dem Nebensatz stand, wo du sagst, macht zwar Spaß, aber im Grunde ist es völliger Crap, so eigentlich gesagt. Ja, das ist halt dieses, wir wollen natürlich auch Klicks einsammeln. Mach ich das dann sauer? Ich bin erstaunlicherweise, erstaunlicherweise ist so die Hälfte dessen, was ich so tue, ist ja Schreiben mittlerweile, also es oszilliert zwischen Schreiben und Moderieren. Ich muss kurz oszilliert, Google. Ich habe zwar Regie studiert in München an der Filmhochschule, aber... Ich finde das so geil, wie wir immer tiefer graben. So jetzt, ah, okay, jetzt wird es richtig tief. Was ist das auf Seite 60 der Autobiografie? Aber vor allem, ganz kurz, sind nicht eigentlich die letzten Seiten von jeder Autobiografie beschreiben, wie man anfängt, die Autobiografie zu schreiben? Und dann ist das so ein Zeitspiral. Das ist eigentlich nie, müsste eigentlich. Ich glaube, ich würde meine Autobiografie damit beenden und dann entschloss ich, eine Autobiografie zu schreiben. Ah, dann würde ich das ganze Buch nochmal wiederholen. Genau alles nochmal und dann kommt man aus dem Zeitkreis. Und wenn es so 1600 Seiten ist, das dickste Buch, was jemals geschrieben wurde. Aber tatsächlich fangen die meisten Autobiografien damit an, oder? Dass jemand sagt, so, ich habe mich entschlossen, alles aufzuschreiben, was mir einfällt.
Fangen die mit der Geburt an?
Nee, erstmal sagen die...
Werden die ersten 80 Seiten so...
Nee, erstmal, die fangen immer an so, jetzt packe ich aus, jetzt erzähle ich alles.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, nichts zu schönen in diesem Buch.
Aber es ist nicht geil, dann genau in der Zeit zu bleiben, also quasi in dem Buch die ganze Zeit zu schreiben, wie man das Buch schreibt und halt nie die Vorzeitlichkeit zu wechseln.
Genau, ich schreibe eine Autobiografie ab dem Punkt, als ich die Autobiografie angefangen habe. Eine Autobiografie-Biografie. Genau, eine Biografie-Biografie. Grossartig, einfach nie die Vorzeitlichkeit wechseln. Stimmt, das ist ja mega cool, finde ich auch gut, das stimmt. Wollen wir drei nicht einfach so was machen? Ich habe mal die Biografie... Ich habe mal die Biografie von Anthony Kiedis gelesen, von dem Sänger der Chili Peppers. Das ist so das schlimmste Buch aller Zeiten, weil der so ein super langweiliges Leben hat. Also der ist sehr reich, was sehr schön ist. Und dann schreibt er aber immer nur so, ja, wir haben eine neue Platte aufgenommen, dann habe ich das Model XY kennengelernt, war mit ihr zusammen, dann habe ich wieder Heroin genommen, dann hat sie mich verlassen, dann sind wir auf Tour gegangen, dann war ich wieder runter vom Stoff, dann habe ich ein neues Model getroffen, dann haben wir ein neues Album aufgenommen. Wir waren sofort zusammen. Dann haben wir ein neues Album aufgenommen und dann waren wir wieder auf Tour, dann habe ich wieder Heroin genommen. Also es ist so, es ist ein Loop, sein Leben ist ein kompletter Loop. Aber es ist ja immer so, Autobiografien gibt es ja meistens, ja, Entschuldigung, es ist ein ewiger Loop, es dauert ewig und es ist nervvoll und man denkt so, also dann erzählt wie er Under the Bridge geschrieben hat und man hält das ja immer für so ein super metaphorisches, poetisches Lied,
hat er gesagt, er hat viel mit Mexikanern
unter der Brücke Heroin genommen.
Erzählendungsungs.
Und am Ende des Buchs schreibt er irgendwie so, ja,
jetzt haben wir eine neue Platte gemacht, ich bin wieder clean,
ich fühle mich wieder gut und ich habe jetzt einen Hund
und ich hoffe, er wird mich niemals auf
Heroin erleben. Und so hört das Buch auf.
Ich freue mich auf den Moment,
wo er Heroin nimmt und der Hund so ein Buch. Das sollte ich nie sehen. Ich finde, Autografien werden ja häufig von berühmten Leuten geschrieben, aber ich finde, dass auch oft die normalen Leute, die den Alltag bestreiten, die Leute auf der Strasse, auch viel mehr zu sagen haben. Also was so eine Krankenschwester jeden Tag erlebt in ihrem Beruf und was sie für Sachen durchmacht jeden Tag. Aber diese Bücher gibt es ja auch ohne Ende. Ich finde es einfach viel spannender, als es, nur weil jemand berühmt ist, heisst es nicht automatisch, dass er viel zu sagen hat. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber es gibt auch viele Biografien von nicht bekannten Menschen. Ja, nee, das stimmt. Das Tagebuch der Anne Frank zum Beispiel. Was hat die Erich geleistet? Sich versteckt, am Ende wurde sie doch gefunden. So gut war es also nicht, dass es versteckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das erzählenswert ist.
Ist ja gut, dass wir wieder in diese Richtung reint.
Hat mir da nicht mal eine Sketche-Idee mit Anne Frank, die tindert und sich dadurch verrät?
Oder sie wird durch Tinder gefunden, dass die Nazis tindern und sie finden im Umkreis von zehn Metern?
Genau, dass sie außerdem die Ortungsdienste angelassen hat.
Okay. Naz-Gags! Nazi-Gags! Nazi-Gags! Wir brauchen auch noch so eine Titelmusik dafür. Ja, nee, vielleicht auch nicht. Eigentlich wollte ich mit dir, ich weiß nicht, worin der wieder so reagieren, wie er immer reagiert. Ich mache noch mal nach. Ich wollte mit dir über Jurassic World reden eigentlich.
Das ist ja auch von dir. Wenn es von dir kommt, oh.
Ich wollte wirklich darüber reden, weil ich finde das wirklich furchtbar.
Ich bin riesen Jurassic Park-Fan.
Ich nämlich gar nicht. Mir war Jurassic Park schon immer
scheiße.
Weil ich Dinosaurier
schon immer voll uninteressant war.
Dinosaurier ist das Uninteressanteste, was es gibt.
Du hast Dinosaurier und Tiere. Du bist das Gegenteil. Du hast alles, was du nicht selbst bist, kann das sein? Ich hasse alles, was nicht Menschen sind. Ich finde Menschen toll, ich liebe Menschen, aber alles, mit dem ich nicht per Sprache kommunizieren kann, ist für mich uninteressant. Aber was heißt es denn überhaupt, Mensch zu sein? Ja. Was macht denn für dich diese Superfähigkeit, Mensch zu sein? Ja, was macht für dich ein Mensch zu Mensch? Dann gibt es nicht auch furchtbare Menschen. Wann ist der Mensch ein Mensch? Das gibt furchtbare Menschen, das stimmt. Aber Sprechen ist so eine zentrale Fähigkeit. War wir kriegen bei der McDonalds. Sprechen. Möchtest du in dem Zusammenhang nochmal Norma aussprechen? Norma, sehr gut. Norma. Das ist so eine zentrale Fähigkeit, die nur wir sprechen und sich anziehen du jetzt mal noch so ein Gag... Das nervt wirklich, dass man sich nicht anziehen, oder?
Ja.
Dass sich einfach immer denken...
Ja, und wie lustig denn alle so, oh, guck mal, der Paar, wie er hat einen roten Po.
Wenn er sich anziehen würde, dann wäre in keinem Zoo das so der Gag.
Ich finde es auch furcht, wenn man am Strand ist zum Beispiel.
Ich bin sehr oft am Strand.
Wenn dann immer Kinder rumlaufen, nackt rumlaufen, also wenn Eltern Kinder nichts anziehen.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Okay?
Oh Gott, oh Gott. Und dann Kinder nackt rumlaufen, also wenn Eltern Kinder nichts anziehen. Jetzt ist gut. Okay? Oh Gott, oh Gott.
Und dann Kinder nackt rumlaufen.
Und man kriegt einen Ständer, ne?
Gut, dass ich das getraut habe.
Die ganze Geschichte war nur eine Rampe dafür, dass du das sagen durst.
Nee, aber das ist doch nicht schön.
Das ist genau wie die.
Ja, Kinder können rumlaufen, wie sie wollen.
Da ist das ja egal. Sind ja Kinder. Okay, sind auch Menschen. Also du verzeihst Menschen alles eigentlich. Das war gerade jetzt dein Punkt, dass Kinder nackt durch die Gegend laufen sollen, oder was? Ja, genau. Mich stört, dass Kinder nackt durch die Gegend laufen, weil man andauernd dazu gezwungen wird, sie nackt anzusehen. Das ist doch nicht schön. Aber wie viele nackte Kinder müssen rumlaufen, damit du permanent nackte Kinder im Zwang ausgesetzt bist, permanent nackte Kinder. Man muss da doch hingucken. Man muss da doch hingucken. Man guckt ja da auch nochmal der Schitten. Ja, aber du musst ja nicht fotografieren. Das ist doch so. Die Fotos hätte ich mir sparen sollen. Mein Anwalt hat mir auch nicht geraten, darüber nicht mehr zu reden, weil ich Tabubruch. Ja, aber du hättest dich auch nicht selber aufs Foto mit drauf fotografieren müssen. Das war ein Fehler. Diese Selfies da, das war nicht gut. Nee, wir hören jetzt auch auf. Ich glaube, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung, das war schön. Das war echt cool. Wir hatten die Möglichkeit, uns jetzt mal so kurz so zu fühlen, als wären wir in Gästeliste Geisterbahn-Orsammel-Mitglied und das fand ich total schön. Ich habe eben schon zu ihm gesagt, wir werden nacheinander, werden wir die beiden anderen auch einladen, getrennt voneinander, sie einzeln befragen und das genauso machen, das Konzept nochmal quasi, werden wir genauso. Vielen Dank, dass du dabei warst, Nils, dass du die Einladung angenommen hast. Ja, sehr gerne. Ich finde, du hast eine ganz eigene Sprache gefunden in der Folge.
Ich finde, du hast ein paar Sachen gesagt, wo ich auch wirklich nochmal drüber nachdenke.
Und ich finde, wir haben heute eine Seite von dir gesehen, die man nicht immer sieht.
Und danke, dass du dich so geöffnet hast.
Ja, für euch.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Für die, die es nicht gehört haben, herzlich herrschwulbeautet.
Das ist ein kurzes Sankt, was wir noch mit euch.
Danke, dass du so ehrlich warst.
Vielen Dank.